Robert Crandall is the former chairman
and CEO of American Airlines he is with
us this morning Bob so good to have you
with us from which you can tell from a
distance is Tony Fernandez handling this
situation as well as he possibly can and
and we need to remember while asking
that question that Malaysia for example
the Malaysian government particular came
under so much criticism for the way it
shared information in the wake of the
disappearance of mh370 well I think
Tony's doing all that he can Brandi he
said he's obviously is expressed his
sympathy and concern for the passengers
as we could he said he's announced it
that they've got appropriate that people
from the ill on it as Airlines do
they'll put a whole crew of people out
there too I deal with each individual
family to try and be as responsive as
possible to be obvious concerns of those
people and he's on the scene and
prepared to make care whatever
information he gets available to others
and that's about all he can do at this
point you know Bob it's Betty here I
hate to be you know I don't want to get
into conspiracy theories or try to read
too much and just certain trends Bob but
you know this is as Brendan was saying
earlier you know could be if in fact
this plane is lost and it is crashed and
all are killed would be one of the worst
if not the worst years in aviation in
over a decade what is exactly going on
why are these these incidences that
we're hearing about the major ones
happening among Asian airlines is there
something to read in that you're a smart
woman and you you have seen enough of
these things to know that it it isn't
sensible to speculate until we know
what's happening these we've had a
number of these things but but you need
to keep in mind that so far as we know
at least and they're not similar that is
they they are all tragedies they're all
shocking but they at least the ones we
know about today have been for quite
different reasons Bob just just have to
wait and see
what what turns up when this one I think
I'll be very surprised if they do not
find the wreckage and I'll be very
surprised if they aren't able to get the
black box one thing Bob that many of
these Asian airlines do have in common
is that they have expanded at an
unbelievably rapid clip in the case of
AirAsia alone this is a this is a
company that back in 2008 had 78 planes
today has a hundred and sixty-nine in
service so more than double the number
of aircraft in the air in that short
space of time we're talking about only
six years should we be asking the
question whether they've been expanding
too quickly well I think we should I
think I think it's perfectly appropriate
to ask the question the answer in this
particular case at least as far as the
experience of the fight was concern is
that these are very experienced people
on the pilot in this case had some
23,000 hours I no reason to believe that
training is deficient in any way and so
until we know something something more I
think all well the question is certainly
valid and needs to be asked but I don't
I don't say in any sense believe that
the answer is going to turn out to be a
friend Robert one of the things that the
two flights have in common this one and
Malaysian air 370 are that neither were
carrying the the type of satellite
equipment that would regularly update to
the satellite to give a sense of where
the airplane was I know that some
carriers like Air France have
retrofitted their entire fleets to make
sure that that's available but it's very
expensive it's about thirty thousand
dollars a plane help me understand from
your perspective what's the cost benefit
analysis you do as an airline to decide
whether or not you want to update your
entire fleet at that cost well the
answer I think the answer here and this
is one of those things about with an
area where in my view we need regulation
this is not something where where we
need to be dealing with cost-benefit
trade-off this is simply one of these
things a lot to be done because the fact
is nobody wants to take off rcn airplane
take off and simply lose lose track of
it and not be able to have installation
so I I do hope that the world's
worldwide aviation afar
is what but come to a conclusion that
this is something is going to be
required for commercial ever right but
Bob I mean I believe the iata has
already come out and made
recommendations to upgrade technology to
upgrade their technology in certain
aircraft and the airlines have pushed
back well yeliz need to stop pushing
back in government's need to make the
point look I from an airline from an
airline's point of view as you know you
folks know perfectly well elings don't
pay for anything passengers do so the
fact is if an airline spend some money
to provide this kind of technology it's
going to raise the price of every
individual ticket by a dollar by dollar
and a half by two dollars not by any
material amount and we're going to have
what I think society as a whole will
believe is a positive energy